okay so you
put your album out it's 2019 right it
was like
ended 2019 yeah pandemic hits you have a
baby
by the way congrats on the baby you
stopped doing coke
yeah and by the way y'all that is not
hard to do
it's not hard to stop it's not hard no
it's it's it's oh it's hard to stop
yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah you were
busting down the same time though but i
was you was doing a lot of cocaine boy
i was sure i was the coke head man i
don't i'm not trying to take pride in
that but
would it like like when you're on like a
drug like cocaine
is it ads is it hard to figure out how
to be productive without it
after a while yeah see that's where my
problem lies
like i have i've been doing coke for
eight
like seven years and i'm now
almost 10 months clean you feel me thank
you
and it's like it's weird because
i built my fan base and my music
a lot of it was about cocaine a lot of
it was cocaine heavy yeah
and you know to go from that and that
was the inspiration you know i snorted a
couple lines write a couple lines
and it was just that you know now you
take that away
it's you know it's like i'm finding a
whole new inspiration but i feel good
about it
you know i feel like you know
it's i don't know but that that drug is
addictive bro it makes everything good
everything is it true when you try to
[ __ ] on cocaine it's hard to keep your
dick hard
if you do too much now if you do just
the right amount you're gonna [ __ ] all
night
uh-huh now you gotta cause that cocaine
dick is a thing
hell yeah so do you like you take the
[ __ ] it's like whiskey dick you drink
too much
whiskey well you know what i do with the
whiskey dick if i know if i know i'm
just getting shitty
i gotta [ __ ] my wife i hit the gas
station get that that rhino
oh my god
you know about the rhino i don't know
about it but i know about it
hey man that [ __ ] works bruh listen no
me too but you got the whistle
you get the whisk i mean i'm not 26 or
33 but like yo you get two shit-faced
and you're like yo i got i gotta run a
marathon tonight i ain't never
i'm i'm scared to pop a dick pill cause
my [ __ ] worked if i [ __ ] around
and pop that but don't worry what if you
can be sick but if you took
too much cocaine it might not work yeah
i haven't been there before but but if
you had a rhino on deck
that's why i don't do coke no more fair
enough you don't need it man stay hard
team's there we're good